حذرت نائبه مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكي
للشرق الاوسط دانا سترول في مقابله خاصه
مع الجزيره مما وصفته بمخاطر التعاون
العسكري المتزايد بين ايران وروسيا على
منطقه الشرق الاوسط وفي وقت نفت روسيا في
مناسبات عده تقديم اسلحه متطوره الى ايران
اشارت تقارير غربيه الى تطور التعاون
الدفاعي بين الجانبين خصوصا منذ اندلاع
الحرب في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هناك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات الى اي ماده تبدو
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والدول
الغربيه محقه في انزعاجها مما تصفه
بالتعاون العسكري الروسي الايراني
المتنامي وما هو رد طهران وموسكو على ذلك
كيف تنوي واشنطن والعواصم الغربيه الحديثه
لها التعامل مع هذه الوضعيه لما تحمله من
تاثيرات سياسيه وميدانيه في ظل تقارير
يقول احداثها ان موسكو وطهران خططتان
لبناء مصنع انتاج للمسيرات في روسيا الى
اين قد يذهب هذا الاستقطاب الدولي في ضوء
الملفات الخلافيه المعقده بين الجانبين
كالملف النووي وغيره واي انعكاسات ستكون
له على ان المنطقه
[موسيقى]
اذا اعين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والنيتو لا تغادر التعاون الروسي الايراني
خصوصا في جانبه العسكري محصيه عليه
الحركات والسكنات تعاون تقول تقارير غربيه
انه يمضي نحو مستويات غير مسبوقه خصوصا
منذ اندلاع الحرب في اوكرانيا وهو التحول
الذي صنع وفق القراءه الغربيه بل صنع
مصلحه روسيه ايرانيه متبادله طهران تدعم
موسكو بالمسيرات في الحرب التي تشنها على
اوكرانيا فيما يقدم الرسل الايرانيين
مقاتلات ورادارات وانظمه دفاع جوي لمشابهه
اي هجوم اسرائيليا او امريكيا محتمل ضدها
نائبه مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكي للشرق
الاوسط دانسترول حذرت في مقابله خاصه مع
الجزيره من مخاطر التعاون العسكري
المتزايد بين ايران وروسيا على منطقه
الشرق الاوسط
سيكون هناك استعراض للشراكه التي يبلغ
عمرها عقودا من الزمن مع هذه الدول وكذلك
لسبل التعاون والتشاور لمواجهه التهديدات
في المنطقه وعلى مستوى العالم وعلى راسها
طبعا ايران وانشطاتها المزعزعه للاستقرار
في عموم المنطقه والتهديد العالمي الحالي
الذي تمثله بسبب تعميقها التعاون مع روسيا
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من الكويت
الدكتور عبد الله الشايجي استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه الكويت ومعنى من الدوحه
الدكتوره فاطمه الصمادي الباحثه الاولى في
مركز الجزيره للدراسات والخبيره في الشان
الايراني مرحبا بكما سنبدا معك دكتور
عبدالله الشايجي من الكويت بالنسبه للغرب
والولايات المتحده ما هي
المخاطر من هذا التقارب الحاصل على
المستوى العسكري بين ايران وروسيا
يعني الخطر ان ايران عندها اوراق يمكنها
ان تستخدمها في المواجهه مع الغرب لا يعني
نؤكد بان هناك اصبح الان ايران في وضع صعب
اقتصاديا عندها خيارات ولكن لم يتحول
التقارب والعلاقه الى شراكه استراتيجيه هي
شراكه مصلحيه بين دولتين محاصرتين من
الغرب في عقوبات على ايران ويوجد ايضا
عقوبات على روسيا ولكن ايران عندها اوراق
يمكن ان تلعب بها بذكاء وكذلك بقدره على
ان تناور يعني يرى الغرب بان ايران تساعد
روسيا في المواجهه في اوكرانيا التي دخلت
عامها الثاني هناك مسيره ايرانيه شهد 136
هناك تحالف عسكري بدا يتبلور ولكن ايران
صوتت بالامتناع عن ادانه الحرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا ثلاث مرات لم تؤيد الحرب او لم
تقف ضد
او يعني تستخدم
الاعتراض على قرارات الجمعيه العامه طبعا
روسيا تستخدم ورقه ايران بشكل فعال لتضرب
الغرب بشكل واضح ولكن المسيرات الايرانيه
قدرتها ايضا محدوده ولكن الخوف هو الان ان
تتطور هذه الشراكه العسكريه الى تزويد
ايران
بطائرات سخوي 35 التي كانت محجوزه لمصر
منذ 2019 ولكن بسبب الضغط الامريكي لم يتم
تسليمها الى مصر ويبدو بانهم الان كما
تقول التقارير الغربيه سيتم توجيه بعضها
على الاقل 24 منها من المقاتلات التي تغير
من موازين القوى عندنا في منطقه الخليج
العربي وتعطي ايران نوعا ما من يعني سلاح
طيران الذي تفتقده ايران منذ ايام الشاه
يعني لا يوجد سلاح طيران فعال عند
الايرانيين ولكن
الان في شيطنه لايران في الغرب بشكل واضح
انها تدعم روسيا تدعم حربها ضد اوكرانيا
من الدكتوراه في القسيمه
من الدكتوره فاطمه صمادي الدكتوره فاطمه
لو فصلنا في الاستفاده الايرانيه من هذا
التقارب وهذا التعاون مع روسيا خصوصا وانه
كما يبدو هذا التقارب يعمق ازمه ايران مع
الغرب
في جزء هذا نعم صحيح لكن ربما من المفيد
ان نتذكر ان تعزيز العلاقه مع روسيا ليس
قرارا ايرانيا يعود الى هذه السنوات
الاخيره استطيع ان اقول انه جاء بناء على
تقرير قدم من مجلس مجمع تشخيص مصلحه
النظام في العام 2008 منذ ذلك العام راى
هذا المجمع انا من مصلحه ايران ان تعزز
العلاقه مع روسيا منذ ذلك التاريخ وحتى
اليوم يسير منحنى العلاقه بين روسيا
وايران بشكل
تصاعدي نعم في جزء منه هذا يشكل نوع من
التحدي امام المنظومه الغربيه خاصه الدول
الاوروبيه ولذلك نلمح نوع من التغيير في
موقفها تجاه ايران خاصه مع في عهد بايدن
مقارنه بسياسه الدول الاوروبيه اثناء فتره
ترامب لكن بالنسبه لايران هناك بعض
مزايا الاستراتيجيه التي تستطيع ان تحققها
من خلال العلاقه مع روسيا ولذلك في
حساباتها خاصه وان الرهان على الدول
الغربيه في اطار تنفيذ الاتفاق النووي لم
يكن رهانا صائبا ولم تستطع الدول الغربيه
ان تنفذ بنود الاتفاق وحتى القناه الماليه
التي اقترحتها للتعامل مع العقوبات
الامريكيه فشلت لدرجه انها لم تنجز الا
ثلاث معاملات ماليه مع ايران لذلك في
الحساب الميزاني الاستراتيجي ايران تعتقد
ان التوجه شرقا بما فيها العلاقه مع الصين
ايضا هي في البعد على البعد طويل المدى هي
الافضل لمصلحه ايران
خاصه مع استمرار مساله العقوبات واستمرار
ما تسميه ايران بالتعنت الغربي في اطار حل
الموضوع النووي وايضا ادخال ادخال ملفات
اخرى جديده الملف الصاروخي ملف المسيرات
وما الى ذلك لذلك كلما ازدادت العلاقه
تعقيدا عن الدول الغربيه وامريكا فهذا
يعني تقويه العلاقه مع روسيا وهناك ملفات
في بعضها اقليميه في المنطقه
بانعكاسات كل ذلك على الملفات في المنطقه
ولكن دعونا نتوقف عند بعض التقارير
الغربيه بخصوص التعاون العسكري الروسي
الايراني فقد نقلت مجله الامريكيه عن
مسؤول امريكيا قوله ان السعي ايران للحصول
على منظومه الدفاع الجوي اس 3 او اس 400
الروسيه الصنع سيساعد في حمايه بنيتها
تحتيه نوويه من ضربات اسرائيليه محتمله
اضاف مسؤول ان موسكو وطهران قدمت بالفعل
خططا لبناء مصنع لانتاج المسيرات في روسيا
كما ان ايران وفقا للمسؤول الامريكي تضاعف
الدعم العسكري لروسيا عبر صفقات عسكريه
جديده يمكن ان تطيل الحرب في اوكرانيا
وتوفر لها شرايين حياء اقتصاديه ودفاعيه
جديده في ظل العقوبات المفروضه عليها
واستنادا للمسؤول الامريكي فان روسيا تضع
خططا لتزويد ايران بمقاتلات ومروحيات
ومنظومات دفاع جوي متطوره
اعود اليك دكتور عبد الله الشايجي نحن
الان امام تسلسل زمني من النوع التالي
دكتور عبد الله حديث متزايد عن ان روسيا
ستزود ايران بالسلاح حديث عن
اكتشاف جزيئيات عاليه التخصيب من
اليورانيوم في بعض المنشات الايرانيه وهو
استدعى ذهاب رافاييل جروسي الى طهران
وحديث اسرائيلي عن ان التسليح ربما سيمنع
اسرائيل من استهداف البرنامج النووي
الايراني هذا التسلسل كله ماذا يقول لنا
يقول لنا نحن مقبلين على تصعيد من جميع
الاطراف ايران تلعب بذكاء في اعتقاده
بورقه مهمه جدا تريد ان تضمن بانها يمكنها
ان تعود الى الاتفاق النووي بشروطها
اقراصي موجود الان اللي هو المدير عام
وكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه موجود ويوم
الاثنين سينشر التقرير عن مدى تعاون ايران
حول مشروعها و برنامجها النووي
ايران ترى بان روسيا هي وقد تكون خشبه
الخلاص مستفيده من الحرب في اوكرانيا
اسرائيل يعني صار للحين عشر سنوات الى الى
الارشيف منذ منذ 2012 ايران
تهددها امريكا واسرائيل بعمل عسكري ولكن
هذا لم ينتج لانهم يعلمون بانه لا يمكن
توجيه ضربه عسكريه لايران باسرائيل مفردها
او حتى ايران حتى امريكا واسرائيل واذكر
يعني بان موقف بايدن هو موقف متذبذب وليس
واضح
تنازلات من
الدول الاوروبيه الثلاثه بريطانيا فرنسا
المانيا وكذلك يعني تريد ان تحصل على بعض
التنازلات من اجل ان تصل اتفاق نووي وبذلك
يكون هناك يعني لا حاجه للتصعيد اكثر ضد
ايران بانتظار ما ستكشف الايام القادمه
نرى مجد تصعيد وروسيا تريد ان تغرق امريكا
وتواجهها عبر عن طريق ايران بالمسيرات
وبالكلام عن مصنع لانتاج المسيرات روسيا
وكذلك
باسلحه متطوره فاطمه تطوير هذه العلاقه
على المستوى العسكري بين روسيا وايران
ما علاقته بالموضوع البرنامج النووي
الايراني والمفاوضات ايضا مع الغرب
مترابط اذا عدنا الى التاريخ نجد ان
الموقف الروسي من البرنامج النووي
الايراني لم يكن هو الموقف الحالي بمعنى
انه في السابق كانت روسيا من الذين ايدوا
العقوبات ضد ايران وليس هذا فقط روسيا
عقدت صفقه لتزويد ايران باس 3 سابقا
ولكنها احجمت عن تزويدها وهذه قصه رغم ان
ايران دفعت دفعت ثمنها
لكن في السنوات الاخيره هناك تحول في
الموقف الروسي هناك في بمعنى ان عوده
الملف النووي الى مجلس الامن ستلقى معارضه
روسيه وايضا معارضه صينيه وجدنا انه موقف
الدول الصين وروسيا من هذه المساله مختلف
عن السنوات التي سبقت وهذا مرتبط بشكل
كبير
بالتغيير الذي طرا على العلاقه والملفات
العلاقه والم لفات
المصالح المشتركه التي اصبحت اكثر من من
السابق التعزيز مساله العقوبات سواء على
ايران او على روسيا ايضا هي ستدفع الى
مزيد من التعاون خاصه على الصعيد الصعيد
العسكري بالمناسبه ايران كان لديها
محادثات بشان تزويدها بطائرات سوخوي حتى
قبل اندلاع الحرب في اوكرانيا
وكان هناك محادثات لوزير الدفاع الايراني
حتى في فتره روحاني بهذا بهذا الخصوص
ويقال ان كان في اتفاق بهذا بهذا الشان
لكن هذا ما حدث من تطورات انا في ظني انه
يسهل حصول ايران على هذه
الاسلحه وخاصه وان ايران حتى 2020 الملف
النووي نعم بالنسبه للملف النووي
اذا نظرنا الى المواقف الاوروبيه خاصه في
الاشهر الاخيره فهي مواقف مواقف تصعيديه
الدول الغربيه تلوح بالعوده الى استخدام
ميكانيك من ميكانيزم الزناد بمعنى ان تعيد
الملف النووي الايراني الى مجلس الامن
بمعنى عوده العقوبات بشكلها الدولي لذلك
العلاقه مع روسيا من الممكن ان تجهد هذا
التحرك الغربي لاعاده الملف النووي
الايراني الى
شكله القديم بمعنى ان تكون العقوبات اكثر
شمولا وان تكون ملزمه دوليا ضد ايران طيب
دكتور عبد الله المسؤولون الامريكيون
يحاولون
يعني تشديد العقوبات على ايران فيما يتعلق
بموضوع انتاج المسيرات وتزويدها
لروسيا ولكن ايضا هناك اعتراف ض مني ان
هذه العقوبات وان جرى تجديدها ربما لا
تقوم بما هو مطلوب ما الخيارات الان امام
الغرب والولايات المتحده امام ما يحصل
يعني خيارات محدوده ايران اذا اقتنعت
بانها لن يمر ترفع عنها العقوبات بل
ستصاعد العقوبات ضدها ستتقارب اكثر مع
روسيا ستزود روسيا بالمزيد من المسيرات
وفي كلام الان عن صواريخ ايضا تزودها
ايران لروسيا لان يعني كما سماها وزير
الخارجيه البريطانيا
تحالف اليائسين الروسي
الايراني كل طرف يحاول ان يكسب من هذه
العلاقه بوجه الغرب وامريكا تعلم ذلك بشكل
واضح وكذلك اوروبا التي فشلت باقناع
الامريكان بان تليين موقوفهم يعني يؤخذ
على بايدن الان من الحلفاء الاوروبيين
بانه فشل في التحاور مع ايران في التقارب
مع ايران والتوصل الى اتفاق نووي لان
البديل هو ان ايران ستستمر بالتقسيب على
الحين وصلت الى 84% لا يفصلها الا
6% لتعسكر برنامجها المدني النووي الى
برنامج
المشكله الكبيره والجميع الباحثين
الاستراتيجيين يعلقون ان اكبر خطا
استراتيجي ارتكبه ترامب كان الانسحاب من
الاتفاق النووي في 2018 لما كان رئيس
الاتفاق وان تقايض به
الخيارات هو ان يتم التوصل لاتفاق نووي مع
الايرانيين مقابل تنازلات ايران يبدو بان
تتعاون الان في هذه الزياره لامين عامل
وكاله الطاقه المدير عام والوكاله الطاقه
الذريه ويمكن يصدر يصدر تقرير ايجابي عن
ايران وهذا قد يعني في مسارين في مسار
تصعيدي مع روسيا وايران ضد الغرب وفي مسار
ايضا تفاوضي وكل شيء لذلك يجري تحت سقف
الملف النووي والتفاوض لان عقده بايدن
وانهي بها عقده بايدن تبقى مثل عقده
اوباما لا يريد ان تكون ايران في عهد
وتبقى له سنتين في البيت الابيض تصبح دوله
نوويه في عهده وهذا سيدمر ارثه هو تاريخه
بين الرؤساء
ذكرت ان الطائرات التي
محتويها لايران ستغير في موازين القوى ما
انعكاس ذلك على امن الخليج ككل باختصار لو
سمحت
الطائرات سخوي 35 متطوره جدا طبعا انا لست
خبير عسكري ولكن مما قراته يعني هناك ولكن
هي اقل تقنيا وتطورا من
الامريكيه التي موجوده لدى دول مجلس
التعاون الخليجي وكذلك اسرائيل فلا يوجد
خشيه كبيره ولكن هذا سيعطي ايران قدره
اكبر على ان يعني تتجرا اكثر عندها صار
سلاح طيران ولكن مشكله ايران افتقاده
لكميه كبيره من سلاح الطيران التي يمكنها
ان تحدث نقله نوعيه في سلاح الطيران
طائرات معظمها قديمه ومتهالكه من ايام
الشام ولهذا السبب لن تغير كثيرا ولكن
ستعزز قدرات ايران لتتجرا اكثر باتخاذ
قرارات يمكن لم تقل لتتاخذها لولا وجود
السخوي 35 دكتوره فاطمه انعكاسات هذا
التقارب الروسي الايراني على
ملفات مختلفه في المنطقه نعم انا في ظن
انه يعزز من اوراق القوه الايرانيه
اقليميه
ربما تكون اليد المطلقه لاسرائيل في ضرب
مواقع ايرانيه في سوريا التي كانت تحظى
بموافقه روسيه ربما هذا لا يستمر
في المستقبل هذه مساله المساله الاخرى
مساله ان تصبح ايران قادر على امتلاك
اسلحه الردع اكثر اقليميا وهذا يعني ان
تمتلك اوراق قوه اكبر امام التهديد
الاسرائيلي وفي ظني ان ايران لن تبادر الى
الى هجوم لكن وان الدول الخليجيه على وجه
التحديد مصدر الخطر سيكون اذا استخدمت
الاراضي الخليجيه كمصدر للتحديد ضد ايران
او الهجوم على ايران في ذلك الوقت انا في
ظني ستكون في معرض خطر جديد لانه المشكله
هي في الاثمان الكبيره لاي عمل عسكري ضد
ضد ايران
ولذلك انا استطيع ان اؤكد ان ايران لن
تبادر باي عمل عسكري لكنها بالتاكيد سترد
على مصدر الهجوم وهذا يعطي ربما
دعوه للدفع نحو حلول سلميه خاصه الملف
النووي ولذلك راينا الدبلوماسيه القطريه
والدبلوماسيه العمانيه تسعى بشكل حثيث
لايجاد حل للموضوع الملف النووي الايراني
بشكل سلمي شكرا لكم من الدوحه الدكتوره
فاطمه الصمادي الباحثه الاولى في مركز
الجزيره للدراسات والخبيره في شان
الايراني ومن الكويت الدكتور عبد الله
الشايجي استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
الكويت شكرا لكم على هذه المشاركه معنا
الى هنا هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر شكرا لمتابعتكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]